الريهان وعلى انهيار اقتصاد روسيا لم ينجح
والعقوبات الاوروبيه اضرت بهذه الدول بحسب
الرئيس الروسي فيلادي مير بوتن بوتن قال
ان العقوبات على روسيا تسببت بتضخم قياس
في الدول الاوروبيه وان اقتصاد بلاده صامد
على عكس ما تمنى الغرب روبل تحول الى احدى
اقوى العملات في العالم هذا العام خلال
اجتماع مجلس التنميه الاستراتيجيه
والمشاريع الوطنيه الروسيه اضافه بوتن ان
الغرب شلنا عقوبات عدوانيه غير مسبوقه ضد
روسيا ومحاوله سرقه احتياطات موسكو من
العملات الاجنبيه واعتبر الرئيس الروسي ان
السلطات ورجال الاعمال في روسيا عملوا
بطريقه مركزه ومهنيه وان المواطنين اظهروا
تضامنا ومسؤوليه مجمل المعطيات بحسب بوتن
ادت الى توقعات داخليه منخفاض الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي باثنين ونصف في المئه
وليس كما توقعت مؤس غربيه ان يصل الانخفاض
الى 20%
وخلافا لما يحدث في دول اخرى اشاره الرئيس
الروسي الى ان مستوى الاسعار في السوق
الروسيه بقي دون تغيير تقريبا منذ مايو
بينما ترزح دول اخرى تحت معدلات تضخم
مرتفعه جدا بحسب قوله
[موسيقى]
في قطاع الطاقه قال الكريم ان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتن يعتزم توقيع مرسوم خلال
ايام يحدد رد روسيا على فرض الغرب لسقف
على سعر صادرات النفط الروسيه حتى الان لا
تزال تبعات قرار دول مجموعه السبع بتحديد
سعر النفط الروسي ب 60 دولارا للبرميل غير
واضحه اما روسيا فقد اكدت ان قرار الحظر
وتحديد الاسعار سيدفع البرميل الى مستويات
مرتفعه مجددا لانه سيصيب الصناعه بالخلل
لكن ما هي خيارات موسكو للرد خبراء في
التوقعوا ان احد الخيارات يتمثل في تحويل
مبيعات النفط الخام التي كانت موجهه الى
اوروبا نحو الشرق وبخاصه الى الهند والصين
اللتين ربما تقومان ببيع النفط الروسي الى
اوروبا عبر قنوات ثالثه وباسعار مرتفعه
خيار اخر وهو ان تشتري شركات طاقه عالميه
الخمر الروسي وان تنقله من ناقلات روسيه
الى اخرى في اعالي البحار لبيعه في
الاسواق الاوروبيه على انه نفط من بلد
ثالث اما الخيار الثالث فهو تخفيض انتاج
النفط وبالتالي رفع الاسعار نتيجه زياده
الطلبيه في السوق
[موسيقى]